evil dead is a fantastic horror film if
i could [ __ ] one horror movie this year
it'd be evil dead i [ __ ] love this
movie i left the theater with such big
enthusiasm and the most mysterious
erection i have ever had this movie is
the definition of why horror movies are
made so many joyous words to describe
this blood vest it's brutal it's [ __ ]
gory it's humorous it's fast-paced and
at times it's [ __ ] terrifying it's
that rare occasion in a horror movie
where the amount of gore actually makes
sense the cinematography is beautiful
the effects are awesome at times is so
violently over the top that it actually
makes you laugh
i'm laughing just thinking about it
so [ __ ] funny
the actors are nothing really special
but they're definitely rock solid they
did improve upon the characterization
from the original evil dead the idea of
everyone being there so mia could kick
her heroin addiction made things much
more justifiable the emphasis on the
brother-sister relationship made
everything more personal putting
exorcist looking shake in the film gave
me a boner it's thrilling that's the
[ __ ] word for it just a pure
frightfest it's got everything from
extreme gore to terror to supernatural
horror to fascinating effects it feels
like a horror ride almost as if it's a
halloween horror night's maze just a lot
of hardcore brutal terror one of the
best horror remakes i've ever seen let
me get straight to the point here all in
all i gotta say evil dead got it super
right
all right guys thanks for checking out
my video if you liked the video why
don't you go ahead scroll to that
comment box and tell me your favorite
points about evil dead or the original
evil dead just share with me what you
thought and if you want to see a more
in-depth review of evil dead go ahead
and check out my show that i do with my
buddy jerry called reasons to see where
we have special guest star alyssa marie
on the show where we'll give you reasons
to see and not to see evil dead and last
but not least if you want to get updated
every time a new review is out
go ahead and subscribe
on the link right there